à l'histoire du jour la semaine dernière
un homme a été interpellé par la bque
devant nos studios euh il voulait
absolument me voir et se montrer
apparemment agressif euh avec les les
les personnes autour du studio il a
tourné autour des studios de 10h à 15h
la sécurité a donc été obligé d'appeler
la police il aurait crié au moment de
son interpellation Allah Akbar fils de
[__] je vais vous crever vous ne savez
pas ce qu'il va se passer euh vous allez
voir ce qu'il a ce qu'il a dit puisque
on a Bruno pomard qui a toutes les infos
Gill également euh il a été donc
interpellé la semaine dernière petit
rcap et on en parle juste après
regarder il y a quelques jours un homme
qui avait félicité l'auteur de
l'attentat d'aras et qui avait proféré
des menaces contre Cyril Hanouna sur les
réseaux sociaux a été condamné à 18 mois
de prison ferme il a dit voilà tout le
mal que vous avez fait à la Palestine
vous allez payer je le jure vous allez
payer c'est que le début monsieur
Hanouna et jeudi dernier un individu a
été interpellé par les forces de l'ordre
devant les studios de TPMP un individu
qui se serait montré menaçant et qui
aurait tenu des propos inquiétants je
vais vous crever un homme interpellé la
semaine dernière devant les locaux de
TPMP que s'est-il
passé merci Bro pomard d'être avec nous
et Gill aussi he t toutes les les infos
Gill kel pouvait réagir d'ailleurs
là-dessus dans un instant pour nous
donner votre analyse alors il s'est
passé quoi Bruno alors bon alors il y a
un individu qui est venu évidemment
devant les studios de de de Canal Plus
qui souhaitait d'abord te rencontrer
hein il a été conduit contte tenu du
dispositif de sécurité qu'il y a ici
effectivement c'est pas du tout évident
de pouvoir rentrer dans ses locaux et
c'est une bonne chose ouais cont tenu du
contexte actuel que que nous connaissons
et les risques terroristes qui sont
présents partout dans le pays cet
individu a été interpellé par la BAC là
encore une fois on voit le le travail
considérable que mett les bacs que ce
soit les bacs jour les bacs nuit en
civil ou pas d'ailleurs mais
l'efficacité s prouvé encore une fois là
ils sont passés à plusieurs reprises ils
ont vu un comportement d'un individu qui
était pas normal ben ils l'ont
interpellé tout simplement avec les
propos qu'on lui connaît alors bon
effectivement pour alors les propos
est-ce qu' vous pouvez nous les redire
s'il vous plaît g tu les as peut-être
oui alors il y a donc Israël wallah je
vais te tuer vous savez vous êtes tous
morts bande de traître puisque vous avez
dit aussi Allah Akbar fils de [__] je
vais vous crever voilà les les les
phrases qui ont été notées vous ne savez
pas ce qu'il va se passer phrase
menaçantes qui ont été prises très au
sérieux et en fait Cyril ça a commencé
dès le matin c'est ça qui a suscité
quand même la grande inquiétude des
services de sécurité ici qui ont été
très réactif puisque dès 10h du matin
ils ont repéré un homme cet homme il
rodait
autour des studios h et à un moment une
un véhicule est entré tôt le matin donc
la grille s'est ouverte une grille
derrière s'est ouverte et l'homme a
essayé de s'infiltrer il a été
intercepté et ce qui a beaucoup perturbé
la sécurité qui a agit très efficacement
c'est que cet homme il était au
téléphone en FaceTime avec quelqu'un il
semblait filmer repéré il parlait à
quelqu'un on n pas entendu ce qu'il
disait mais voilà à dès le matin il
était là en repérage il voulait vous
voir pour vous parler du conflit
israelllo-palestinien il disait que vous
l'avez conduit deux fois déjà voilà et
on m'a même dit c'est à confirmer mais
je suis quasi formel que cet homme était
déjà venu dans le public c'est ça
exactement ça vous avez cette info aussi
j'ai l'in d'accord donc il est déjà venu
voilà j'ai l'info alors c'est ça Breno
oui l'enquête alors l'enquête judiciaire
effectivement les les les enquêteurs ont
euh mis sous le label je dirais de
apologie du terrorisme avec outrage et
violence sur des du personnel
dépositaire de l'autorité publique en
l'occurrence il battu avec les policiers
d'abac bon euh l'apologie du terrorisme
c'est difficile je parle sous le
contrôle de Gill kepppel évidemment qui
est beaucoup plus spécialisé que moi euh
à partir au momentù on dit Allah Akbar
ça peut avoir deux je dirais presque
deux
définitions même plus mais pour être
très très très factuel c'est B le Allah
Akbar qu'on dit à travers les les cinq
prières que font nos compatriotes
musulmans tout au long de la journée et
il y a le Allah Akbar du terroriste qui
passe à l'acte et qui effectivement dieu
le plus grand donc je me suicide pour
pour lui qu'il étaé assez violent avec
les policiers oui oui oui il a été il a
été interpellé Manu militar par les les
les copains de la BAC he qui ont fait un
travail remarquable qui l'ont évidemment
amené devant l'OPJ pour pour avoir plus
d'informations pour connaître un petit
peu le le le fond du du dossier savoir
s'il y avait des complicité savoir s'il
y a il y avait des éléments factuels qui
permettent de de déterminer
effectivement le la le délit
l'infraction et il s'est avérit que Ben
effectivement le le le le parquet a
classé s suite voilà sur sur sur les
éléments que la police a amené le code
371 on appelle ça on a classé l'affaire
sans suite en disant tout simplement que
suite à une expertise psychologique le
gars ne représentait pas de danger waouh
ça fait quand même un peu peur quand on
sait parce que si à la limite c'est le
cas on le met sous injonction médicale
c'est-à-dire on le fait suivre là
visiblement quand on connaît la
psychiatrie dans ce pays et tout ce qui
se passe actuellement on peut
s'interroger sur le personnage sachant
qu'on a beaucoup de d'individus de de ce
type dans dans la nature c'est fou ce
que vous dit oui g oui parce qu'il était
calme le matin auprès des services de
sécurité et l'après-midi il était
extrêmement agité puisqu'on parle de
rébellion hein il a voulu taper les
policiers à coup de point et ce qui a
vraiment surpris les policiers de la BAC
quand ils sont passés avec deux voitures
c'est qu'il a essayé de se cacher oui
donc c'est vrai qu'ensuite on parle d'un
profil psychologique perturbé mais dans
le process de 10h du matin jusqu'à 14h40
le moment de l'interpellation il y a
quand même une volonté de repérer de se
cacher de parler à d'autres gens qui
sont-ils c'est encore la question est-ce
qu'il a été envoyé par quelqu'un ça on
ne le sait pas mais ce ce cette
conclusion de on met ça sous le tapis
elle nous paraît bizarre à Bruno et à
moi c'est oui totalement c'est assez
inquiétant d'autant que les les
policiers là-bas je pense sil tournent
dans le secteur je pense qu'ils avaient
déjà repéré l'individu maintenant vous
savez ce que c'est tout le monde peut se
promener même si on dit Allah
Akbar il même problème c'est qu'il il a
été violant avec les policiers de la
même pour ça il était relâché oui benah
oui oui ben oui il tombe sous
l'injonction de oui problème
psychologique save a des problèmes
psychologiqu on peut aller mais
rappelle-toi il y a quelques temps Cyr à
re la la l'infirmière qui a été
poignardé à mort ce même individu en
2017 avait poignardé des gens il a été
reconnu respesponsable il a ré il il y a
peu de temps il a tué cette infirmière
donc voilà il faudrait ça il faudrait
s'informer ou faire venir peut-être un
spécialiste de la psychiatrie pour nous
expliquer comment ils font pour déceler
le fait que un individu n'est pas
dangereux même si poignard de quelqu'un
oui Jacques réagir làdessus non mais non
mais non mais ça m'a enfin en tous les
cas je me souviens de d'une enquête que
nous avions faite sur le la
problématique des fous dangereux en
France il y a je crois 10000 personnes
qui sont recensées en tant que tel et je
comprends pas enfin plutôt je sais que
l'une des grandes problématiques c'est
que il y a pas suffisamment de de centre
d'accueil et queil y a un énorme
problème avec avec tous ceux qui sont
déséquilibrés mentaux en France parce
queil y a pas les structures d'accueil
parce qu'il y a pas de suivi et parce
que tout ça ce sont des des potentiels
personnes qui sont qui sont dangereuses
et souvent on les retrouve dans des
phénomènes d'attentat il il y a eu des
études qui ont été faites là-dessus les
injonctions de soins ne sont pas suivi
pour autant on manque de psychiatre de
psychologue tout ce imagine tout le
monde le sait c'est donc là là il a été
complètement relâché oui alors il va
être quand même surveillé évidemment par
les services de police hein les les les
policiers sont pas totalement stupides
encore une fois c'est encore un profil
qui est quand même qui reste dangereuxin
et donc il va falloir d'une façon ou
d'une autre le traiter mais
malheureusement on n'est pas à l'abri de
d'une récidive sur
mais qu'est-ce qui est fait concrètement
quand on surveille une personne comme ça
parce que si elle veut comme si elle
allit chercher du pain et au final elle
vient ici elle fait ce qu'elle a à faire
qu'est-ce que c'est du c'est au jour le
jour la nuit aussi comment c'est c'est
toute la difficulté de nos services de
renseignement que ce soit des GSI que ce
soit nos équipes de bac de jour de nuit
tous ces gens qui patouillent tous les
jours pour notre sécurité à toutes et à
tous hein c'est la difficulté de de
trouver d'arriver au bon moment
lorsqu'il se passe quelque chose on peut
pas tout prévoir malheureusement et le
terrorisme ce que parlait Gill kpel tout
à fait terrorisme d'atmosphère mais tout
ce qui réalise ces actions qui parfois
on se dit mais pourquoi on l'a pas arrêé
avant mais d'abord parce qu'il y a pas
commission d'une infraction il y a pas
l'élément matériel moral et légal pour
dire que ce
g parnormément deéaction làus et on a
d'autres éléments qui arrivent là sur
cette affaire on se retrouve dans dans
quelques minutes